Now let's focus on signifiers, for feedback and
discoverability as they relate to our timebank user interface.
>> The actions that we need to do, initiating a transaction initiating
an exchange with someone so how do you tell, so you gotta
be in range. With somebody else, for example doing an exchange. What
are some elements of feedback that would say, when somebody is in range?
>> The
noise, yeah, ping.
>> So, you got sound channels?
>> Or just visual feedback, if you see a map and see other people on it.
>> Alright, let's draw out. Each of you draw like five,
five examples of how you know when somebody else is in range.
>> Like geographical range you mean?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Let's, let's say it's, in it for those of you technical. It's like
Blue Tooth, and needs to be within ten meters but we'll say ten feet.